so ripley's going to be joining us
a new puppy my friend what's great the
first oh i tried to go right for the
balls nope
i know dogs she's trying to get you
canceled yeah dude you got all this heat
coming in she's like let's
but what's so funny is the
the first time we did the podcast
it was at my friend who lives here in
these chairs but in his other place oh
okay so now he's like moved in i
recognized the mics and i felt like this
was a similar chair but i wasn't gonna
you freaking dog you're not gonna get my
bottle
it's non-stop
it's non-stop she'll chill out she's a
puppy yeah yeah yeah
but yeah it's
it's pretty persistent yeah but you know
what it's better than paying for a hotel
i'd do it heck yeah yeah when you're
visiting another scene if you can crash
with another friend that's the best
exactly yeah yeah so this has been my
best friend since high school freshman
year oh awesome so he's lived out here
for about 12 years and then he's engaged
and now he's like a grown-up we're grown
up how old are you 33 now it's weird
yeah i just turned 34 and 34 hit me
different like it's like middle
different it's mid 30s now yeah and
you're so close to the 35 we both are
and which is like a weird it's a weird
one to think about you know what i mean
and you had a kid yeah you have a son
now i have a son which is another that's
another weird thing for me to be like
i'm a dad now which is bizarre because i
don't i don't really feel like i mean i
i feel more like a dad the longer he
he's alive and stuff like that right but
uh it's still like
when i look in the mirror and i'm not
like i'm a dad you know
it's like a weird kind of feeling
how has it changed you like i've heard
when you have a kid that it's almost
like taking like the blue pill or
something like you see the world
completely different
you know i don't know if it's
necessarily that i think it definitely
does change you in a way where uh
i think i'm more it's weird i think i'm
becoming more sensitive to certain
things than um
than i was before
uh
ripley
me being honest and then there's this so
comedy just a dog yeah
like how does kids change when there's
like a puppy here
but uh
i i think it motivates you in a very
different way where i think before uh
it's very singularly it was for my wife
and i uh
but when there's another when there's a
child that you like made with another
person yeah it's a different
level to push you to be like
like i need to do this versus like i
have to make this happen now like it's a
different mentality like i definitely
like i've always been a hustler but
something definitely flipped internally
where i was like i got to work a little
bit smarter now i'm like i'm working
really hard right now but i got to work
a little bit smarter now because there's
less time in the day for me to do things
what are some things that you changed
just work smarter
uh i think
starting to say no a little bit more
because i'm a yes guy all the way i say
yes to everything and
i have tried to be a a team player as
much as i can um with all the shows and
everything that i do but i've slowly
over the years i have stopped doing the
shows that i was part of ensembles with
and trying to focus more on my singular
projects yeah for kind of the next steps
of my career also it's good so you're
not always just known as a sidekick guy
yeah you can kind of get put in that for
sure and just just be seen as that sure
and just be booked as that too yeah yeah
yeah
wow yeah this is so funny this dog is
just gonna it'll be fine everyone it
adds to the comedy if there was one
person you ever get tired of looking at
joel and i there's a beautiful little
french
she's just chilling with us i'm i'm glad
that this is happening with you though
it's the perfect person oh dude i don't
yeah i don't care
but that's yeah that's something i have
noticed in like the big the big
motivator and i appreciate you even
saying yes to do this again because this
is your third time coming on here but
is like as comedians
and it's something that really hit me i
wonder i don't know what to do about
this is this just what it is you're a
dad how do how do we mitigate this um
you would have to put the toy i would
have to hide that you'd have to hide the
toy like or you'd have to put it like
literally back there but she might bring
it back she definitely oh this is yeah
she'll just bring you
and then she'll pull it back um
i guess we could just kill her i guess
maybe that's the thing we should do
um hey ripley yeah i don't think she's
gonna chill you think she'll chill yeah
yeah even i mean i don't even if she
just jumps up i'm fine it's the
squeaking yeah yeah i understand that
that for audio but um
yeah that'll be fun there you go buddy
so that's a big thing
as comedians i mean we're essentially
like media companies now like the amount
of that's like put on us of like okay
writing and refining your stand up yeah
booking shows okay now you need to be
creating content and distributing that
content and marketing yourself there's
like there's a lot that we're expected
to do now that is just part of the norm
of being a comedian and yeah in my
opinion you're someone doing it
i can't think of that's so funny she
just got it
i can't think of someone who's doing it
at a much higher level than you like the
amount that you're doing
is it's inspiring as like a fellow comic
of like what's possible but like you
really are spinning a lot of plates and
they're working is the other thing well
thank you that's nice you just say um
i would well
going off of uh you you don't have to
thank me for for doing the show anyway i
i like you a lot as a person and as a
comic and i
one thing you ask like one of the shifts
of like
like
you know becoming a dad and stuff like
that i don't do
i
don't work with people now like as
that are not like if they're not
hard-working and like positive people
like like i
literally
do you know what i mean yeah yeah that's
like something where i'm like okay well
that's an easy thing to go not that i
really did that much before but i would
throw every once in a while i'd be like
yeah they like they're asking me i'll do
it but i don't really want to if i'm not
like passionate about it i'm just like
there's no time for it so it's like why
why do it you know yeah like i'd rather
just like do people's things that are
like like i see you hustling like with
your clips and everything that you do
online and like around the comedy scene
and stuff like that so like i want to
you know what i mean it's a
reciprocating
thing like i want other people to do my
stuff who i'm putting out the work and
they see that like a lot of times for
like jeremiah wonders
they i know that comics don't watch full
episodes of things but they see the
clips they know it's funny and people
will agree to do the show because they
see the funny clips and they see the
work that goes into
editing those clips and stuff like that
so
yeah it's contagious too like the people
you surround yourself with like energy
is contagious and
even as like an open micro it's like if
you're in an open mic and you're just
around other comics they're they're just
hanging out just to get drunk and not
get better and develop as comics that's
going to rub off on you the same way if
you surround yourself with comics out
there hustling being productive then
that's going to rub off on you and
inspire you as well oh yeah i always
love following
people who are really sharp joke writers
at the comedy store and stuff like that
because it's like
a
you got you're forced to bring it right
after that and then it also motivates
you like oh maybe i could be writing a
little bit more yeah like that yeah yeah
i never understand the mentality of
somebody who wants to go after somebody
who's not good on a lineup like oh great
now i'll really get a kill it's like
well let's see if you can kill after
somebody who's already destroyed the
room and see what you can do exactly
with your flavor and stuff like that
yeah getting out of your comfort zone
which is something you said on our first
interview is like one of your favorite
quotes from del close is like follow the
fear oh yeah so like what what are you
currently what are you currently fearing
uh
having possibly a second kiss
my wife is already brain she brought it
up like last night she is
wanting to have a second uh baby and i
i don't know i don't i'm definitely not
mentally there yet uh we'll see if it
happens
or not uh i said that i i want to make
sure that we both really want this one i
i don't want to just you know obviously
that's another big project to commit to
for sure yeah
but uh that's like that's like personal
lifestyle but uh uh comedy stuff
it's really um
really
the things that i'm i'm following the
fear for right now is
you know you're acknowledging that i'm
putting out a lot of stuff um i have
i've been having some stuff that's been
hitting lately which is awesome uh
but i put out so much stuff that flops
as well
and that i think goes with part of the
fears like
it's cool that certain things are
hitting um but those things that are
hitting there's so many things that are
not at the same time that i'm literally
like
i'm putting a thousand percent into
like when i put out a clip i'm like i'm
really proud of that clip like i like i
don't like to just put out content just
to put out content i think that there's
like a funny reason like oh this could
catch on or i like this
so
most of the time i want to say
probably upwards of the
95 percentile of things that i put out
are not hitting wow but i would say
those five percent are the ones that are
important that are the things that lead
to the other things yeah yeah and that
95 percent people still see they still
see like a scrolling like
it's always in the feed they may be
engaging but it's like jeremiah again
jeremiah
if you're not engaging it's like maybe
subconsciously you're still top of mind
to people no that that is important that
does i mean that definitely does go a
long way like where there's certain
people who will just be like this is the
one thing and it's like well the chances
even just like with
the internet and how it works and like
it may not even show up in people's
feeds exactly
you can't just be like i'm gonna put out
one great clip a week it's like that's
just not how it works anymore
what is your
um
what is your workflow around content
creation because i go through i'll go
through like stages motivation i was
like i'm doing it baby five times a day
until we hit and then like a week later
i was like all right what what else what
else you know what i mean like yeah how
how to help us jeremiah like because it
seems like half the game for comedians
now and it really hit home with me when
i did a show recently
and a comic killed
and then he got off stage and i was like
that was a great set he's like yeah but
i forgot to record it so i didn't get
any clips and i was like comics are now
thinking and stand up as
not maybe as in the moment as much as
how can i record this to then post it
online and not maybe focusing on the
crap itself i honestly think that that
is a dangerous approach of um
of thinking like if that's
if that's your approach then you got to
be
a little bit careful because at the end
of the day you need to be working on on
the jokes and if you i i look at it more
as like when i go on the road
i do record all my sets if i happen to
capture something that's great i get a
clip out of it but i'm not looking like
if i end a show i'm like
there wasn't enough clip worthy moments
it's like
there's a lot of shows that all all
had i'll have a great set that night
but then i checked the tape later it
doesn't translate because i'm calling
back things that were in the room and
stuff like that it's very much for that
audience but that audience had a great
time and that that's my job is like i
want to make sure that audience had an
amazing time and they had a little
mental vacation from their problems
during that hour exactly yeah so i think
that's a weird approach but i think
that's a very like i think a lot of
comics are doing that now where they're
like i got to get this clip for tick
tock or i got to get it for ig reels or
whatever or wherever you're posting it
and uh
yeah at the end of the day i think that
you know i think we can all
focus on
working on the jokes and that's what i
told him because this was like a newer
comic and and that's when it struck me
as like oh this like next generation of
comedians this is how they're coming up
this is how their starting comedy is in
this like internet world of you got to
record this grainy crowd work clip with
terrible audio yeah and then throw it
online as much as possible yeah that i
mean they're just doing uh what they
know like like i was talking with
somebody else like when we were growing
up the only people who had clips were
people who had full-on specials but now
you can get a great hd camera and record
your own set and
you know yeah put your own stuff out
there yeah and i told him i was just
like just just get funny dude not to
sound like the the geezer and comedy i
mean i've been doing it 12 years
and i think content's valuable but i was
like dude just be grateful you killed
like focus on the moment there's gonna
be more shows there's gonna be more
clips but like give yourself credit you
you killed and you're new at common you
did great you know so
it's just it's so weird to see
that mindset in comedy now is not as
much oh getting on stage as much as
possible developing my act it's more
like how do i broadcast myself well it's
a it's a different thing because it's
like uh if
it's it's like a weird lottery ticket
thing because if you throw stuff on tick
tock and it goes viral
you know i've seen people who start
touring off of like a handful of uh
successful videos on tick tock and stuff
like that and it's a it's a weird thing
but
the thing is it's like you can do that
and that's great but
can you sustain like are those people
gonna be legitimately happy and excited
after they leave your show yes you don't
want to turn and burn mentality where
you're like oh yeah i saw that tick tock
comic once and like yeah i wouldn't see
them again
my goal is like after i headline a club
especially in a city i've never been to
is like when is jeremiah coming back
exactly i want to do that good of a show
where i and and for the people because
at the level i'm at like they still you
know paper the rooms and stuff uh like
at different clubs that i go to it's
like a mixture of people who come out
from podcasts and then they'll like uh
paper the room uh and those people who
maybe got free tickets or
are seeing me for the very first time my
goal is to make them a fan where they're
like i'll pay for a ticket the next time
because this guy was good and like he he
he did his thing yeah and that's part of
also like you said you put out content
that you're excited about and that you
feel good about and not you're not just
spraying and praying like because
sometimes i feel like comics will post a
clip and it's like
if this went viral is this what you
would want to be known for you know sure
sometimes they're just throwing out
everything it's like but if it pops is
this do you want to become that comedian
right you know what i mean it's it's a
fine line to walk
yeah
so how many times are you posting a day
do you have like a schedule um i usually
will just do a minimum of one a day i
mean but there's people out there who i
talk to like if you really want to grow
your following you kind of need to be
posting like at least two or three times
a day which i
mine's a little bit slower like organic
growth of people from
podcast appearances and different stuff
that i do um
so it's it's a longer
path but i'm also like i'm literally
doing already everything i can and i'm
like unless
i had a full team of people i wouldn't
be able to do the three that's so much
content just to put subtitles on i wish
that um
the internet had not trained people to
like subtitles because it's the biggest
pain in the butt of all the content yep
it's literally like the most
non-creative part of my job is every
week slapping subtitles on something
that i think is funny and then you're
second guessing yourself
on the on the first hour and you're like
i've watched this so many freaking times
is this even good like i guess it is i'm
like i've already subtitled it let's
freaking do this you know are you doing
all your editing still uh i do for my
clips uh yes but i have um
uh people who um i
that we pay that uh for scissor bros to
help us edit those episodes now because
they got a little bit
too insane i was doing that solo for a
while and then with jeremiah wonders my
buddy gage t arena he's been helping me
produce that show for years and he's
been helping out with scissor bros
editing but uh basically we'll co-edit
like different things we'll pass rounds
of notes and stuff like that oh yeah and
then it'll come back to me as like uh
like more of a
finished product where i might polish a
little bit and then i'm making all the
clips and stuff like that okay yeah
cause i've definitely seen even just
like your clips are becoming more like
stylized and it's not just like a static
shot but there's movement within the
editing and there's almost like a
character within the actual editing so
yeah i was i wasn't sure if you were
doing all that or if you had started to
outsource because it's i mean the output
and the quality
like the quality isn't suffering even
with the high output which is so
difficult to do
yeah that's the goal with uh with all
this stuff you don't want to just be
starting to put out stuff where you're
not
happy or excited about it where you're
just like well i gotta post today cause
like if i don't if i'm not feeling it
like then i won't post on certain days
if i don't really have something that i
like really need to do i'm not just
going to post like something like you
know like that's what the stories are
for they disappear like i am i'm going
to the grocery store right now those
disappear for a reason those are not
they're not quality enough to just live
somewhere where people are like man i
remember this day a year ago when
jeremiah went to the bank that was so
cool
i've been guilty of like posting like
i'm just creating content i've like set
it into the camera and that's it like
right i've gotten caught in that cycle
like well i just gotta i gotta be
posting something or else i'm never
gonna like whatever imaginary yeah yeah
like person's gonna kill me if i don't
post today it's it's
it's i mean it's a lot of pressure
content police man dude i mean it is all
you over give you a fine it's kind of
ridiculous like i've had some
some clips hit
and like podcast and like stand up clips
and things but it's like
it's not to a point to where like
there's that much monetizing going on
like it seems like you've kind of
figured out
and i still don't even know what i'm do
like i don't have like a voice i feel
like or i don't think people come to my
page the podcast they do but like my
comedy i don't think people would come
to my page and then me would be like oh
cool i'm here for this you know it's
kind of still all over the place a
little bit yeah i feel yeah it's it's
it's um
it's a weird one to uh
yeah try to to figure
that out
my stuff ebbs and flows sometimes people
are all about the podcast clips and then
other times they're all about my
stand-up clip so they're like it kind of
goes back and forth there's a weird
thing like whatever
is hitting that week like i happen to
post something that did well on ig this
week just because i it happened like a
month ago where a drunk guy walked on
stage and i posted that a day after the
oscars thing because i hadn't posted it
yet i was saving it i was like i don't
know if i want to put this out and then
i was like well this is too perfect like
this is so weird so i put that out and
you know what i mean like yeah i guess
it's being
uh
just more thoughtful about stuff like
what i said like are you actually
excited about this
do you want is this what you want people
to see not just content to be spewing
content that's really good i you're
this is really helpful in just terms of
like kind of how you make your decisions
like you said you only like to be out
around people who like hustle and are
positive mindsets so it's kind of like
helps you decide what you will do and
what you won't do and also help you
decide what you will post and won't are
you excited is this something that you
like you feel excited about not
obligated oh yeah and and i like uh
have gotten one of my favorite things
that that um since we're talking like
why not nerdy social media stuff right
now yeah yeah the instagram
collaborator feature um the
collaboration feature
is one of the best things that i've seen
as far as like
any platform has figured out because the
main problem with sending a clip is you
notice somebody is like if you send me a
clip for this podcast and you're like
hey can you write something about this
and this is all the info
you just click a button you're like and
if they don't want to do it it's not a
big deal because you're like ah it's all
good like but like the option is there
they can at least see it and if they
want to click accept they can yeah but
there's like it's way less pressure to
like making a a full post and it's less
of an ask for somebody like where you're
like hey if you want to do it just click
the button if not
just ignore it you know what i mean and
that's
been cool to
work with other people where it's like
on podcast stuff where a lot of people
wouldn't reshare before that feature and
now they're like okay yeah i don't have
to type anything up i don't have to do
anything so
that's helpful for sure how do you how
do you come up with so many ideas like
do you do you spend time just generating
ideas
what do you mean like okay like you're
like i mean scissor bros alone like the
the absurd things you guys do
yeah like consistently i mean like an
ice bath
we don't have to go down the list of
that's like one of the tamer ones but
it's like
and then you've you've done this for
years i mean coming up in second city
and even like in the groups you've been
a part of and stuff but it's like
part of content creation is like the
ideation yeah and so you're you have
your stamp is on your content like
there's thought it feels like that goes
into them to make them stand out more uh
that's the goal i mean the whole premise
behind scissor bros and it's a hard show
to keep
uh recreating ideas for and stuff like
that because
you know the longer we do it naturally
there really is so many things that we
can do like in a garage space like where
the studio is at like it's a confined
space you can only do so many challenges
whether it's like a physical
thing or like an eating thing or
a stunt thing within that space so it's
like okay we got to spend the time now
to do a separate shoot
in a different location like all that
stuff takes a lot of time and prep and
stuff like that and luckily
uh i really enjoy doing it that's i mean
the coming up with the ideas
if you are not having fun
i don't know you're not gonna come up
with the idea that you want like if
you're not enjoying yourself and having
a good time like i really enjoy
steve my brother steve lee like i enjoy
being around him
and even if we have to do work we we sit
back all the time every once in a while
when we're brainstorming or we're
shooting like a dumb
ad for one of our sponsors that we're
grateful to uh to have on like sheath
underwear right here snap use promo code
scissor bros
my wife will be so proud right
but uh we sit back like every once in a
while and you're like can you believe
that we are even making any money at all
doing this we're like we start laughing
because we're like it's hanging out with
like one of your best friends and you're
just riffing out ideas and stuff like
that so
i'm super fortunate and grateful to to
do
projects that i that with people that um
are fun and the idea i've i still have
even though i'm not doing as many
ensemble shows i still always think of
in an ensemble mentality even with like
my show stand up on the spot i'm still
like we just did a special that we did
that we filmed in houston and i picked
some of my favorite
texas comics to
that they haven't had stuff really shot
before i was like you know what i'm
gonna like
shoot this special out of my own pocket
and it's gonna be a showcase for
for them and myself and it's still like
i'm getting to showcase a team of people
who i think are worthy of
the spotlight and that deserve a look
from other people who may not know who
they are so i still kind of think in
that and that kind of team mentality
even when i'm doing more solo stuff yeah
i think i i'm definitely guilty of that
still almost like that solo mindset like
i guess i do stand up it's it's i don't
know like i'm i need to be more
collaborative um
i feel like like seeing like you you've
always been more collaborative and i can
see like how far you've gotten not
putting everything on your shoulders but
really surrounding yourself with
inspiring people you know
so i feel like i need to get better
about collaborating even if it's in
content creation or like doing skits
like you do you know
it's um
i don't know i i get in this
i don't know it's like i i gotta do it
all or it's just not gonna get done or
and then it ends up not getting done you
know type deal well the the the greatest
thing for me when i collaborate with
other people is just getting
another person's perspective on
something
where
because
when you start talking out like even
like if you all occasionally run by a
premise by somebody or something like
that
just running it by somebody who's a
friend they'll be can they'll be
confused by something in the setup or
something like that that's an audience
that's technically an audience member
right there like you're they're helping
you
bypass a lot of work just being by being
like i don't get what do you what do you
go do you know what i mean so i still
like to run by
things by people who are willing to to
listen like when i go on the road with
friends and stuff like that i'm like hey
i'm thinking of this like like they're
like ah well that i don't understand
what you mean by that that saves you a
lot of time where in an audience
something's bombing and then you're like
i don't get why they're not connecting
with it you know that
yeah we do comedy is getting more
collaborative i do that is the spirit of
like the community we built at hot
breath
especially during the pandemic when it
we were just we just started this
facebook group that's now like over 5
000 comics just that's awesome helping
each other out you know so
i think that is definitely the next wave
is being more collaborative but it's
almost like i need to be
i need to be better about practicing
also like what i preach or whatever of
like being supportive and positive and
then i'd be like all right but i don't
i'm not collaborating as much i guess
you know
except for this dog
she's so persistent oh yeah
what is that
hey ripley ripley she's just staring i'm
putting i have a pile of toys off to the
side that she keeps bringing
yeah go look out the window yeah dude
let's just look out the window together
for a second
sunny los angeles day this is good it
feels good it's good to be back out here
yeah it makes you feel famous
even though the house was crowned
couch it was great awesome it was dope i
didn't know
when i was going up
so they just like said my name and i
just like had to run up there type deal
so that was fun gotta love that that was
fun to you know
i'm at the i'm at the comedy store i
freaking hate that i checked my dms
after the producer did dm me like you're
next but what i'm i'm trying to get
ready for my set i'm not yeah yeah i'm
not looking at instagram dm's right
before you go on exactly so they just
said my name and i was like oh and i
could run up there and like so it felt
rushed but it was fun like the set went
well
dope um
yeah it's always just good when you talk
about facing that fear getting out of
your comfort zone it's definitely good
to get out of your scene
and just start
performing in places you're not
comfortable or familiar with because
that helps you just to grow and develop
that much more oh yeah
yeah so i'm gonna do
uh i'm doing chocolate sundaes on sunday
and um have you ever done chocolate
sundaes at la factory
no it's so weird i did
th this is what's interesting about uh
uh
sometimes you're seen too early with
certain things
and this wasn't a scene too early thing
but sometimes people only associate you
with one thing and that's honestly why
i've stopped doing certain ensemble
shows because as you know
i've used my sacks a lot in different
comedic things
there's legitimately
certain bookers that still don't know i
do stand up
and it's insane like with the amount of
output that i do and everything
that's how crazy it is sometimes where
people
are like yeah you musician right
so uh chocolate sundae is the guy who
books that shout out to pookie what up
um
he
i brought him years ago they were doing
a chocolate sundae this is uh at this
point almost a decade ago
i brought him some of the best
improvisers in the city for they were
gonna shoot a chocolate sundae
uh comedy special with different
improvisers and sketch actors stuff like
that and they ended up doing it but i i
basically i put together a showcase for
him
of people who i
thought were really funny because i was
because i was connected in the improv
scene
and
we all showcased and did an audition at
like his offices and i think at the
laugh factory or something like that
and i ran into him like a little while
after i told him i was like hey man like
what i was doing i was like i'm a
stand-up i want to do your show
and uh he's like yeah that's great and
then like i ran into him like a few
months later he's like how's that improv
going and i was like i was like
and i and he's like
remind me for a spot yeah
and i called and then like he's like hey
hey how's that improv going he just you
know what i mean yeah so like sometimes
you're seen as something where it takes
so much for people to reassociate
what you do so it's important that when
you're seen early on that's why like i'm
always telling people
to um
don't worry about like being seen at the
clubs early because
people will sometimes remember those
sets for a very long time so if you're
not ready then that can hurt you pretty
badly yeah for sure yeah so i just
stopped asking i was like ah this dude
just thinks i do in bravo and it's not
worth my time to just be like hey pookie
you want to book me a chocolate sundaes
i'm that white guy who keeps
your spots i know you want a lot of that
right now on chocolate sundaes
well i mean when i started uh in atlanta
like
i just came up in the urban scene like
white i was never cool all right let me
move i don't want him to yank down that
yeah or her
she's about to yank down the camera yeah
like that's where we'll do yeah that's
not a toy we'll draw the line there is
that strap in the uh the frame are we
good
i'll put it back here just to be safe
it's the great thing like
i've gotten like roasted on youtube
because in a lot of my interviews like
they'll make a point and i'll look at
the camera but i'm really looking to
make sure the camera's still going but
people are like you don't have to look
in the camera idiot
like what are you you're like i'm
getting gold right now i want to make
sure that this is still recording i look
at the camera all the time for for
certain things and sometimes people
don't like it i'm just like whatever i i
don't i don't care
yeah
oh maybe for this part yeah okay we got
ripley up here now so maybe this will be
good yeah
oh oh yeah so i'm just saying i came up
in the urban scene in atlanta just
because i never got booked on like the
cool hip shows
i just i guess i was just never in like
the cool kid table so i was just like
where can i get stage time and it was
always the urban rooms because those
rooms were
like they weren't political they were
literally like are you funny or not or
oh yeah are you hustling or not like it
was pretty cut and dry like that it
wasn't like
but dude is yours so
yeah exactly
so that's just kind of i think how like
those are the most honest rooms i love
those rooms yeah rooms are
if you're not funny you freaking know it
real quick
and if you are you feel like a
king in those rooms for sure so i i love
the just the stakes alone
of that yeah because going into it like
there is a little bit like when you hit
the stage in a more urban room
they're kind of like what's this guy's
deal you know what i mean but they they
do that with most comics hit the stage
what's this person's deal
they funny
let's see
you know the real star of this episode
is this dog
i feel like i'm on scissor bros right
now yeah this is one of the challenges
one of the challenges is you cannot eat
this dog who can keep conducting a
podcast interview while a dog is
literally being the most add creature
ever
is that joy what's over here that's look
at the window
down the strap on the camera
awesome thank you so much ripley for
being making a cameo see i was talking
about wanting to collaborate more look
ripley's helping me out here dude the
numbers alone for ripley on this episode
are gonna be huge
i hope so i'm ready i'm ready
i'd like something to pop you know i've
gotten i've gotten a taste here and
there of like what's possible even in
like turning on youtube adsense you're
like oh 200 this month that's cool hey
but it always feels good to
get even a little bit of compensation
for
our dream you know what i mean like even
when it's these little bar gigs if
somebody throws you 20 bucks after a set
it's never not gonna feel good yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know what i mean like it's
i really do enjoy yeah it's it's still
uh
yeah so i don't know sometimes i get in
my head of
like some sometimes i have to catch
myself it's like even last night at the
comedy store i was like it was uh crack
them up and it was in the belly room
and so i'll stop to catch myself like oh
yeah but it's not the or or oh it's not
the main room like i i have to like
i mean i don't i mean i'm just trying to
be transparent of like yeah like a
professional working comedian
that i've been doing it full time is
like i still have to reframe even like
this is cool i'm performing the comedy
store i was like but it could always be
better instead of having gratitude you
know yeah i think that's uh
you know
that's something that all of us comics
do
uh my wife is really good about helping
me with
perspective on that kind of stuff just
because
it's real easy to get down on yourself
yeah because all of us could be farther
along
literally even at the top
even like even at the top of the game
you still like
i mean
it's so it's so overly talked about
right now and we'll like we'll quickly
talk about it and move on but like dude
the fact that
chris rock
had to deal with a heckle at that level
the biggest stage in the world right
just goes to show you guys it's never
gonna stop so just be grateful for what
you have good point that's a really good
never gonna stop we're always they're
always gonna be faced with something
that like oh this sucks or i'm not where
i want to be or this happened to me it
shouldn't like i deserve better like
it's literally never gonna stop so like
get out of this business if you can't
handle some licks along the way because
like if you're not loving it this is
just not worth it because there's so
many other things that if you're happy
with doing that i always encourage
people to do like hey i'm thinking about
doing stand-up i'm like do you love this
yeah do you every ounce and fiber being
do you absolutely
you can't see yourself doing anything
else
then
do stand-up comedy but if not
it's not worth it yeah it really isn't
if you can be happy doing something else
isn't it yeah it's not worth it because
it's free for a long time for a very
long it's free for us yeah so that's why
like i'm so much about having fun and
surrounding yourself with positive
people because
the reality of it is a lot of us
like for all our careers it's gonna be
you're gonna struggle
maybe on the longer side than the payoff
side
so why would you
not be having a good time and
surrounding yourself with positive
people and just be in the muck and mud
of negative negativity and stuff like
that
if that's gonna be the main part of your
life and career
so that's why i always seek out like i
said positive people who are fun and
hard-working because i'm like that's i
just want to reflect what other people
are doing that are positive so why not
yeah it's like i mean bert christopher
is such a good example of like someone
who just grinded for like decades and
then now like he's reaping what he was
sewing but like he could very well not
have as well but it seemed like he was
having fun
throughout the entire process yeah man
all right being a party life of the
party
i know we did this whole
uh during the pandemic we did this whole
social media campaign
where it was um like basically like
getting burnt on uh hot breath and we
called it bird watch and there were all
these memes made of like bert's face on
baywatch and stuff
and it actually got his attention and he
said he would do the podcast and then um
and he like sh he like put me on a chat
thread with his like i guess the person
who books everything and then we've just
been kicking the can down the road ever
since but he's he's on tour he just
filmed a movie based on a story yeah he
went viral like he's he's he's filming a
lot he's doing a lot yeah
so we're uh we're coming for you bert
but i mean i have no doubt it'll happen
it's just funny when you're like yeah
and everyone in the because like the
community got behind it people were
making memes people were when we would
post something everyone would tag him
like we really worked to get on his
radar
yeah we're trying to do that with tom
delong on scissor bros it's still like
an ongoing joke it's an ongoing joke
that like literally continues like
we like kind of like
our scissor siblings like we like almost
like it was almost harassment for a
little while there were so many scissor
emojis on like all his posts and stuff
like that and it was just like funny
because we were trying to
get his eyes on this music video that we
made which is on the new scissor bros
album which is out right now it's called
tom delong where you where have you gone
and uh it's all about tom de long it's
like our ode to tom and how we're fans
of him and how we want to hang out and
it's like if you listen to lyrics it's
pretty creepy
but it comes from a it comes from a good
place
[Music]
has he has he responded or anything no
but like we
so steve went to high school with him
that's the weird thing about it
like that's why it's like oh it really
could happen
but like he didn't respond to bobby
either and it's like he's not
you know what i mean like bobby has even
more of a reach obviously uh than steve
and he didn't respond to bobby to do
tiger belly so i'm like that's a
giant podcast if he's not doing that
like it's gonna be pretty hard to get
him to a challenge on scissors
yet yeah yet i could see him doing like
a tattoo challenge with him cause he's
all tatted up right yeah yeah yeah i
think so yeah well yeah we did uh yes
yeah
steve has a scissor bros tattoo now
which is
which is kind of crazy and then we gave
someone a tattoo uh dresden made
on uh on one of our episodes like we did
scissors on him
yeah oh my wait you did the test he did
it oh he was cool enough he's a
professional tattoo artist he's like
he's like yeah you can do a little
scissor on my arm so we we free drew
scissors and then
we did the tattoo steve and i i did one
half and steve did the other yeah yeah
that's what's something we brought up in
the first interview is like jeremiah
wonders it's like you seem like you're
creating
like a podcast but with like the show of
it in mind like this could be a tv show
you know and it's like you've done that
with scissor bros as well
yeah the way i look at jeremiah wonders
is it's very much like a um
an incubator for
other projects like i will throw
like i've been doing stand up on the
spot way longer than jeremiah wonders
but
i will in place of jeremiah wonder's
episodes when we drop like a stand up on
the spot special i'll put that in the
audio feed so people can listen to it as
a podcast
and then it also goes out on youtube as
a special so it's kind of like
all-encompassing as like you can watch
it on video just like the normal podcast
or you can listen in your car like like
it's a stand-up album
does it perform as well
uh yeah yeah it does um i mean the the
stand-up on the spot specials do
they outperform jeremiah wonders big
time
but that's like it's a group
collaborative effort it's you know me
with a few other comics versus just
me and a guest who may or may not
promote right that's the thing is like
some of my favorite episodes like the
guests just won't
help at all and like it's like well
your followers won't know it's great
because like they're not following me
right right you know what i mean so they
share i'm like oh they're gonna love it
but like it that that's why like the the
amount of
clips and stuff like that is also
throwing the dart of not just like well
other people see it but like well the
people who i'm working with will they be
excited enough to even share it that's
its own like set of obstacles and stuff
like that yeah that's what i'm noticing
with even like producing my own shows
and things is like to get comics to
share something it's gotta look super
cool or like make it needs to make them
look good or unique and tailored to them
yeah yeah for sure that's that's what
the thing is is like
i fee i feel like we're going to
eventually
figure out something different like with
comedy flyers because they don't work
online anymore hmm
literally
with comedy flyers the way that like if
you want to get real nerdy about the
algorithm and stuff like that the more
text that's on something
uh
the more it recognizes it as an ad that
needs to be sponsored or paid for so
that's why you'll see somebody with a
hundred thousand followers on instagram
post a flyer that has 200 likes on their
page because instagram wants that person
to pay to sponsor the post even though
they're literally not showing it to all
their followers because they're like
this is an ad this is for something that
they're promoting they should pay us so
we will like
like hoist it up oh dude
do you like research these platforms and
like um there's yeah i'll read certain
things and certain things uh every once
in a while like uh for youtube like
they've got videos and stuff like that
every once in a while i was like hey
like find out why this video isn't
performing as well as some other videos
i'll watch that stuff every once in a
while to kind of research it because
yeah you kind of have to do
part of that's part of the the job is
when you're doing this much like
stuff is like if something's not working
assessing the problem and working on it
just like a joke like
you can't keep doing the same joke and
expecting different results when it's
the exact same joke every single time
and it's the same thing like if you do
the exact same kind of content all the
time your numbers are going to go down
yeah that's it's almost like doing like
because our youtube channel is doing i
mean we're almost at 20 000 subscribers
and i'm super excited about it and yeah
which is freaking hard to do on youtube
dude yeah i i love youtube's my favorite
though like i've put more research time
into youtube than anywhere
one i mean just because it monetizes the
easiest and it's like you can
potentially reach the biggest audience
and longevity-wise i mean youtube just
seems to be like it's just gonna be
there so it's like a great place to
build a live instagram could figure out
how to catalog their stuff a little bit
better than they'd be in competition
with youtube in my opinion but youtube
will still remain king because you can
type in and search for stuff
yeah and it's like with instagram i
don't think people consume it in like
they just scroll through your feed and
go look at like old old old videos
versus like youtube they make like
watch all of it from the beginning i
don't know if people consume instagram
like that no it's very like fleeting
yeah it is they don't they're not as
connected like youtube feels like
i mean that's what we're trying to
figure out with it right now is
long-form interviews of us sitting here
don't really perform as well as like a
shorter more like educational clip and
things like that so i'm just
trying to figure out kind of the next
phase of the youtube channel
so like i'm experimenting with a lot of
shorts right now and just kind of like
analyzing various clips and posting some
clips and just seeing what youtube
shorts will pop and then maybe making a
longer video based on that topic okay
but it's all
i mean it's all like
just we're just trying our best out here
man hey man figuring it out just
figuring it out in front of another
camera i look into the camera we're
figuring it out yeah we're figuring it
out everyone
so i i appreciate you sitting down and
taking the time to do this man seriously
on the day that your new album is
released
yeah comment is this your is it the
first comedy store records release or
record uh lp they released uh an ep with
uh rick ingram um
and then this uh this is like
this album is like
almost an hour and a half this is their
first lp
it's an hour and a half of like music
and like little things that uh just best
of moments from uh the podcast but we
for a year this last year every week we
have either
written or improvised a new song every
single episode so we have over 80 songs
now and i could only fit 34 onto this
first album wow so like that's something
that like
not only are we doing the challenge
aspect or the real challenge creatively
has been coming up with that amount of
music in that short amount of time yeah
uh but they're yeah i'm super excited
about it because it sounds really good
and and the way
that we laid it out it it feels um like
a comedy album because we kept some of
the intros and outros of the podcast uh
of us like talking about the song or
like the lead up and building so it just
feels like kind of like an old cheech
and chong kind of recording that's
awesome yeah do you think it do you
think something with this format would
make it onto like serious
that's the goal we're pitching it so
yeah yeah i mean that's definitely the
goal like to put it on some of those
comedy channels uh because
some of the songs are standalone where
you have to you don't have to know
anything about the podcast and they're
just funny comedy songs and then some of
them obviously there are more inside
baseball where like you would kind of
need to know a little bit more about the
scissor bros world to kind of like get
in on the joke but there's some that i
think that that are just good
comedy songs across the board where you
could just play it and be like oh this
is just funny
dude okay so how how can people before
before i ask my final question here how
can like people check out the album or
like where's it where's it at and what
it's on all audio platforms uh-huh um
that is off right now i don't know if
that's oh the battery was low
and i
i when i was packing i had two batteries
in the charger yeah so so we'll still
have the audio going but the video just
died you got it and i observe it i for i
left um the charger in my wall at home
and i left my tripod oh wow like in
atlanta yeah wow okay but we've got the
camera i mean we've yeah we're still
good yeah okay okay but the yeah the
camera died it's on all audio platforms
so
which is
yeah i know that's pretty that's pretty
ironic right funny you can find on all
audio platforms uh
yeah so if you're an apple music person
or spotify or whatever uh
yeah
so um the final thing i want to ask and
this is something like i've been married
today is actually my five year
anniversary congratulations so we're
gonna do like a zoom anniversary uh like
i can't wait to do that with you
you playing your saxophone in the
background yeah i can see that right
right so um i mean my wife has been
just beyond supportive especially as a
comedian and there's no
real like stability there's no like yeah
oh look i got this paycheck every two
weeks and here's my benefits you know
and like i've heard you like reference
like you've like i think your wife is in
the improv world
or she's just she's events
she's adjacent i always say because she
um
she teaches uh kids um
uh improv who are on different social
and emotional uh learning levels so
people who are on and off the spectrum
she helps with and she is a teacher at
uh
at a charter school in la where that's
where she's their social and emotional
learning specialist right now so if
there's like a troublesome kid who's
having issues they kind of like send
them to her
uh to kind of help and and she helps
those kids with improv and different
like games and stuff like that that
she's developed over
um time of we met at second city so like
we she basically took the stuff that she
learned from
second city and then like with her own
methods of like uh like
like being in uh like getting her ba and
like child development and stuff like
that she's written a couple books and
stuff like that about how
improv is so important and helps expand
children's brains and also uh with their
social skills and eye contact and
everything like that so that's yeah what
she does so she's adjacent to it but
she's been with me since the open mic
level so she's been she's a ride-or-die
yeah were there were there any times of
like should i keep doing this or like
has it been support the whole time and
like she's been kind of like a champion
to
i don't know it's just tough like if you
have like a spouse or
just even like a significant other like
being a comedian
it's not traditional there isn't like a
set path of like no it's gonna be fine
because this clip's gonna go viral honey
i promise you know what i mean and it's
like i just
sometimes i want more
this is self-inflicted like pressure
she's not like what are you doing but i
can put the pressure on myself of like i
want to be able to do more i want to be
able to provide more but it's also like
patience and have fun and gratitude and
blah blah blah blah even though verizon
doesn't accept gratitude you know so
it's like
at a certain point you know you have a
spouse you wanna
you wanna be there and you wanna like
show like this work is working you know
but it's it's tough to show that
sometimes i guess
yeah i mean i don't have a question
there i'm just using it as therapy i
guess i think i think it's more like
you know
your wife obviously loves you and we
have a different
we have a different meter for success
than our our spouses do
uh if they're seeing us happy doing what
we do and
uh
you know even if it's not at the level
that we'd like to be performing at
they're gonna be happy because
you're you're making them happy and if
you're doing what you do that makes you
happy ultimately if you found someone
who loves you like that like they're
going to be supportive and championing
you there's obviously ebbs and flows of
of all of our careers where i think it's
harder to be supportive at other times
but
you know my wife has always been amazing
and and she has been incredibly
supportive like where if i you know i
hope to win an oscar someday or
something like that
she would be it would be just as much
her oscar as it is mine because she
helps me do freaking self tapes and
stuff like that when nobody else is
around and like she helps me go over
sides for auditions and she has to
listen to me and put up with me like
like on the lows but she's also there
when when the highs come in too so it's
like it's a cool partnership you know
great man yeah yeah good good okay yeah
i just love the comedians and their
spouses it can be such an interesting
relationship and it's just been
i wouldn't be right here today without
my wife sure a hundred percent yeah i
just said a hundred percent i don't i
was channeling bert christie there
so yeah let's lay on this plane thank
you so much for your time man um
and thank you ripley for making a cameo
um but before we land the planet is
there anything else you want the world
to know
check out uh the new stand-up on the
spot special that's on my youtube page
stand up on the spot houston and then uh
we're gonna be releasing a series of
stand up on the spots uh in the next
couple months which is really exciting
that we've been filming at the comedy
store so oh snap i'm very excited about
that oh snap yeah good freak dude what
are you are you like trying to create
your own like
media company like your output and
distribution is like it's crazy are you
going in that direction
i want my own happy madison someday for
sure yeah i mean i already have
i already have the core group of people
who i've been working with and i'm like
yo if people if we get a legit budget
for this like we can make some amazing
stuff like i've got like
there's a handful of people who have
been helping me
uh with this it's like talking about
collaboration
i owe
uh
their
i owe some serious money someday to like
the crew that i've been working with
um
who have been helping me with these
projects like my buddy gage t arena and
chris mcmillan keel ulberg and van
corona and guys like that who
we've been shooting sketches we've been
shooting
pilots that haven't been seen uh or that
have been pitched that haven't gone
anywhere you know stuff like that where
it's like you know we're all like
betting on ourselves and and luckily
it's a good core group of people that
you know hopefully we will get it make
movies and tv shows with friends and
stuff like that that's that's that's the
dream at the end of the day that's
awesome you know i i love hearing that i
your your enthusiasm is contagious and i
appreciate your
refreshing perspective just on like
focusing on surround yourself with
fun people and also creating
things that energize you i think that
helps with just the overall amount we're
we're creating is if it's fun it'll
energize you even when it's oh yeah work
like you said
yeah cause then it doesn't it doesn't
feel like work anymore yeah if you're
legitimately excited about it then it's
just like oh i can't wait to to do this
versus i have to do this
comedy should never feel like i have to
do this it should be i get to do this
awesome well thank you for doing this
man yeah brother of course you rock i
appreciate your time and wisdom go
support jeremiah go check out his new
scissor bros album and check out his
youtube channel and follow him on social
media it's really
yeah it to get to sit with you and get
some of the rub here is it's really
inspiring and energizing for me to take
forward after this so thank you so much
thank you everybody all right and thank
you ripley for snoring in my lap
oh that was great
it's fun
hope that's what you wanted